foreign
we're actually going to dive straight
into our main story tonight which
concerns voting a practice that was once
sold to youth with the slogan Vote or
Die and given the state of politics
right now for the first time I'm
requesting more information on the
second option
specifically with the midterms now just
two days away we wanted to focus on a
dangerous Trend among Republican
candidates denying the legitimacy of the
last election the fake news big Tech and
blue State liberals stole the election
from president Trump the 2020 election
was a totally rigged election in fact
quite frankly every election since I
think George Washington has been some
kind of a defect in the system you can
say Biden won the presidency kind of
like OJ is innocent
I'll say this those people are
ridiculous but they have been a really
good time just check out this guy I've
never been as happy as he is hearing an
O.J Simpson joke in 2021 and I have two
children and the thing is those people
are not alone a majority of republican
nominees for house senate or key
Statewide offices this year deny or
question the 2020 election results and
some like this guy deny it while trying
to add a bit of spectacle hey Mike
Collins here you pro-trump America First
trucker running for congress here in
Georgia 10. well I understand oh Joe
Biden was in town yesterday to talk
about our elections it seems that he and
Kamala Harris called anyone who
disagreed with the federal hijacking of
this election a racist
well Joe I got some news for you let me
tell you what Georgians really believe
you see Georgians are sick and tired of
we need spineless politicians who won't
fight for Trump get to the bottom of
2020 and fix our elections well if they
won't do it Mike Collins will
send me to Washington okay too many
things to get into there your brain
wants to focus on pro-trump America
First trucker but then wonders why is he
dressed like the world's angriest Target
employee before noticing wait is that a
garbage can labeled voting machine then
also labeled cast ballot as if they knew
that the first label wasn't convincing
anyone but thought that the second one
might then it takes a minute to focus on
the subtle but unmistakable edit points
before the explosion breaking the
illusion that that was shot in a single
take then finally your brain says hey he
opened with Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
think of a racist did he have did he
ever close that Loop or no and
now
District where he's running he's almost
certainly going to win on Tuesday but it
is worth dwelling on the promise that he
and those other candidates are making
that they are going to fix our elections
because that speaks to a real problem
here which is that a troubling number of
election deniers are running for jobs
that can play key roles in administering
elections in their states in fact over
half the country has an election denier
running to oversee their elections and
many of them are expected to win and
look we've talked before about voter
suppression on this show whether that's
through voter ID laws felony
disenfranchisement gerrymandering or
restrictions on mail-in voting but those
tactics take place before you cast your
ballots tonight we're going to focus on
Election subversion which typically
happens after the votes are in it's a
strategy to negate legitimate election
results by simply refusing to accept
them Trump famously tried to subvert the
last election and some current
candidates are promising that if elected
they'll be able to guarantee a certain
result in the future take Jim Marshon he
leads the America first Secretary of
State Coalition and if they win he's
been pretty clear about what that would
mean when my Coalition of Secretary of
State candidates around the country get
elected we're going to fix the whole
country and president Trump is going to
be president again at 2024. look no
wonder Trump likes that message also it
probably doesn't hurt that it's coming
from a guy who looks like a smaller
paler version of him just look at that
man he looks like the Pokemon that Trump
evolves from
so if the plan is this overt and with
potential consequences this die offer
this election the next election and Way
Beyond tonight let's talk about election
subversion and to understand what we're
facing let's revisit briefly some of the
chaos following the last election as you
undoubtedly remember after Trump's loss
he tried a lot of tactics to swing
things back into his favor including
calling Brad raffensberger the secretary
of state of Georgia to ask him for just
a small favor so look all I want to do
is this I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state it's still
incredible to listen to that and a cold
chill ran down my urethra merely hearing
his voice again seemingly forgetting at
one point both how many votes he needs
and the word votes it's genuinely
amazing to listen to someone attempt to
coup with the same focused energy of a
dad struggling to remember his family's
McDonald's order yeah uh can I get a
spicy a Crispy Crunchy chicken and uh
two do you have something called son of
a Baconator here are you the Whopper
place or are you the other one yeah yeah
I'm in the wrong place aren't I okay got
it [ __ ] me
now thankfully rafflesburger declined
Trump's request which left him to fight
his battles in the courts where he lost
over 60 lawsuits challenging the
election results he then famously tried
at the last minute to bully Mike Pence
into refusing to certify Biden's when
including a phone call where Trump
called him a wimp and the p word which I
know is supposed to be [ __ ] but to be
honest the p word sounds like the phrase
Geppetto's therapist uses to talk about
Pinocchio
that you remember all of that there were
also smaller much lesser known incidents
where people further down the chain also
tried thumbing the scale like in Wayne
County Michigan where Trump supporters
raised [ __ ] claims about voting
irregularities in Detroit and a
republican member of the County Board of
campuses there proposed this simple
solution to
to certify
Community other than the city of Detroit
that move outraged the Democrats on the
board and speaker after speaker on the
board's public Zoom meeting you a big
distracted a black City out of a county
and said the only ones that I had fought
at an issue is the city of Detroit where
80 percent of the people who reside here
are African-American right I understand
boys upset there generally when a white
person says I have a compromise and
starts doing electoral fractions that
count black people less those haven't
been great moments for democracy now
that woman later claimed that she merely
wanted more investigation of those
Detroit votes before she'd agreed to
certify them and while after pushback
from Michigan's governor and Secretary
of State she ultimately voted to certify
Biden's win after Trump called her and a
fellow Republican board member they both
tried albeit unsuccessfully to rescind
their votes meanwhile a few days later
at Michigan State canvassing board there
was a similar stalemate its four members
were evenly split between Democrats and
Republicans one of whom refused to
certify Biden's win which meant it was
all on this guy to do the right thing
which thankfully he did with this little
speech as John Adams once said we are
government of laws
not men and this Board needs to adhere
to that principle here today
this board must do its part to uphold
the rule law
and comply with our legal duty to
certify this election
I will be supporting the motion
and that was it a boring guy with
glasses quoting John Adams upheld
democracy I'm just saying get Bradley
Whitford in there and add some stirring
music and you've got the kind of scene
that will make Aaron Sorkin come until
he passed out
and the thing is
those are clearly just two very local
examples but in state after State we
were very lucky that a small group of
individuals in key positions stood firm
Arizona's Republican Governor Doug Ducey
was literally in the middle of
certifying his State's win for Biden
when he got a phone call from Trump but
he put his phone aside and continued
signing the paperwork and I have to say
watching someone screen your call is one
of the most devastating things a human
being can possibly experience and I'm so
glad that it happened to Donald Trump so
to recap the guard rails to protect our
democracy were heavily tested in 2020
while some major weaknesses were exposed
they thankfully held but since then
there has been a concerted effort to
attack the people and institutions that
got into Trump's way Shifting the
landscape in ways that could make future
subversion attempts even more dangerous
now for one thing the further around
election fraud has been stubbornly
persistent with the recent poll showing
6 61 percent of Republicans believe Joe
Biden only won due to voter fraud which
is just ridiculous given that again
there is no evidence of that multiple
States had exhaustive recounts this has
been litigated this just isn't one of
those unknowable things that will never
get resolved like which one of the
Teletubbies when cooked properly would
taste best that we'll never know will we
and I know what you're thinking because
it's what I'm thinking too should we
just all say it at once
Paul exactly of course his Poe every one
of us is pretty sure that on a rainy day
in January absolutely nothing would
taste better than some braised pole over
rice with some ginger with some wine of
course everyone's pretty sure that a
pole that simmers for an hour and a half
after getting properly blanched and
caramelized would melt in your mouth on
that January Sunday Yum Yum yummity Yum
but
pretty sure isn't sure in it we will
never definitively know because you
can't eat Teletubbies there are laws
apparently so all we are left with is
gut instinct unlike election results
which are actually verified sleep with
one eye open you tasty plump clown or
have your thick salted thighs for my
Christmas feast
but the thing is
if you're not a regular consumer of
conservative media you may not realize
the extent to which Biden stole the
election has taken hold and on the basis
of incredibly flimsy evidence perhaps
best exemplified by 2 000 mules a
documentary from conservative [ __ ]
artist Dinesh D'Souza which is just
wall-to-wall nonsense the 2020 elections
were one of the most corrupt in history
see the proof for yourself we tracked 2
000 mules making multiple ballot drops
mules the shocking new movie from Dinesh
D'Souza Philadelphia alone we've
identified more than 1100 mules what is
a mule person picking up ballots and
running them to the Dropbox this is not
Grandma a walking her dog bad
backgrounds bad reputation
mysterious handoffs in dark alleys
people with bad reputations it's nice
that we finally have an answer to the
question what if the wire was created by
virgins
the central idea of this movie is the
claim that there were vote mules who
repeatedly visited ballot boxes and
deposited suspect ballots and the Dinesh
and his friends have identified them
using cell phone data and it would take
the rest of this show to debunk the
movie's claims Point by point but very
quickly there is no way by just using
cell phone data to know whether someone
visited a Dropbox or was just in the
vicinity of one particularly since those
boxes were installed in high traffic
areas meanwhile the only map that seems
to show someone driving around dumping
ballots is fake and another map
supposedly showing a Dropbox site is
actually a stock photo of Moscow with a
third one just the same Moscow map again
but rotated 90 degrees and finally the
whole Theory rests on these mules
repeatedly going to multiple drop boxes
but while they show lots of footage of
dropboxes within the movie none of them
show the same person more than once
instead the filmmakers breathlessly
scrutinized for clues that they claim
with zero proof are evidence of crime
including voters wearing gloves you know
during a pandemic or taking photos as
they deposit their ballots I'm going to
show you a full minute from the movie
where they work themselves up over
absolutely nothing
okay the next one yeah so let me show
you doggo
so dog guy
middle of the day this is actually at a
polling place so the people in line are
waiting to go in and vote early they're
doing it the right way okay now now
you've got some other people gonna walk
up
this lady doesn't care but this guy this
next guy cared he's watching the whole
thing
that guy looks up talks to him got the
ballots under his arm already now he's
got the rest that he pulled out of the
bag
and he's gonna get his camera ready to
take the pictures as he puts him in
there
if you consider the brazenness of this
right this is the middle of the day
there's people sitting there watching
you cheat
people that are doing it the right way
but it's difficult for them to know what
to do except observe and maybe say
what's going on here what did I just see
they wonder what does this all happen
mean if this is happening in broad
daylight and nobody's doing anything to
stop it
but that's not dumbing evidence that is
fully not anything it's just someone
voting
and we need to be absolutely clear on
something here the guy in line that
they're talking about who's supposedly
shocked about the voter floor that he's
witnessing he's looking at the dog
has anybody would the only reason I can
focus on what's going on there right now
is because thankfully they blurt that
dog
otherwise I like him would be gawking at
it and asking who's a good boy until the
polls closed this movie is astonishingly
dumb but it has a real following at
least 50 candidates have promoted or
cited it and it and conspiracy theories
like it have contributed to what's been
called a sea of pervasive distrust with
deniers now channeling that distrust to
burrow into every level of the election
process take the very lowest one
precincts they're small neighborhood
level units centered around polling
places political parties organize in
precincts and local governments hire and
recruit poll workers there Trump's
allies have been working extremely hard
to make sure that they are well
represented at that level particularly
Steve Bannon pictured here drowned who
has made his Precinct strategy a
constant refrain what we need right now
the way the Republican party is
structured is that you can go to a
Precinct become a Precinct committeeman
and then you've got real then you've got
real standing we're building an army of
the awakened and we are taking over
Precinct strategies where taking over
election boards canvassing boards or
flooding The Zone with poll workers poll
Watchers election judges people in the
room it's going to be Maga in the room
counting the votes because only Mega can
count Fair okay okay set aside only Maga
can count fair and just spare a moment
for his room decal which features an
actual sign reading there are no
conspiracies but there are no
coincidences a quote attributed to
Stephen K Batten well you might think
there is nothing douchier than quoting
yourself it turns out you're wrong about
that it's doing that while also slightly
trying to give your name a fancy
makeover because Stephen K Bannon oh
please Steve no one is buying that
because we looked and the K is for Kevin
you're just making your name even sadder
but balance strategy seems to have paid
off propublica found last year that in
41 key Battleground counties there are
at least 8 500 new Republican Precinct
officers or equivalent officials with no
similar search from the Democrats Bannon
and other Republicans have also been
encouraging people to take on jobs in
polling stations while issuing some
troubling advice at one training session
four poll workers and Watchers in
Michigan run by a republican activist
group participants were told to call
9-1-1 and contact sheriffs to involve
law enforcement in any election related
complaints which isn't great is it you
should clearly only call 9-1-1 with an
actual emergency like you know a car
accident or a break-in or when someone
takes off their shoes and socks on a
plane oh yeah I know we're in the sky
but I'm asking you to get a police
helicopter and shoot us down and if
you're thinking that election
supervisors won't stand for shenanigans
like that you should know many have been
driven away one investigation found that
in five highly contested Battleground
States roughly one in three top election
administrators left the job after the
2020 election and when you consider the
kind of personal messages that some
received last time you do understand why
they may not want to do it again this
election is effing rigged
you all know it and you are complicit as
F you lied
you're a traitor
perhaps cuts and bullets will soon
arrive gave my address
234 years ago the founding Caucasian
fathers of America gave us the Second
Amendment
running out Richard
we're coming after you and every
[ __ ] that stole this election
with our Second Amendment subpoenas be
damned you're going to be served LED you
[ __ ] [ __ ] animal enemy communist
holy [ __ ] those messages are horrifying
and by the way founding Caucasian
fathers is just one a hell of a price
because it either comes from the mouth
of a racist or someone with strong
opinions on the casting decisions in
Hamilton because they are a racist
Rogers actually identified more than 900
threats made against election
administrators since the last election
so it is no wonder so many qualified
people are leaving and their
Replacements are sometimes troubling
take Nye County Nevada where their top
County election official was replaced by
this guy Mark comp who not only said
that he believes Trump won the 2020
election he's also promoted 2 000 mules
and has Amplified some of the baseless
hysteria around Dominion voting machines
and look we've addressed voting machines
before on this show they do have some
vulnerabilities but importantly those
vulnerabilities can be counteracted by
having a physical paper trail and doing
risk limiting audits after the fact also
there is no proof that any machines have
ever been compromised in a U.S election
but conf defends election deniers
strongly and he will not budge on it
when pressed if you don't believe the
system was legitimate in 2020 and
created an error where thirty thousand
plus us votes were not counted in the
state correctly
isn't that problematic I don't see as
being problematic at all because I'm
trying to increase voter confidence in
the election in the election space the
machines that count go through multiple
layers of security they are not
connected to the internet and this is
regulated throughout the country that's
that's a perspective there are a lot of
people again the voters in this County
don't believe that and whether it's true
or not their perception is their reality
wow whether it's true or not their
perception is their reality I've got to
say that is a risky stance for a guy
whose name is almost Minecraft again
it's literally not but I've seen this
name written down hundreds of times
while working on this piece and every
single time my brain auto corrects it to
mine camp and eventually my perception
will become reality I'm just saying if
my last name Will conf I definitely
wouldn't give my baby a four-letter name
that starts with an m it'll be if you
like meeting someone named Earl Harbor
or Holly course it feels like their
parents just went out of their way to
[ __ ] with them and all of us
confer suggested that all ballots should
now be hand counted but experts will
tell you that while hand counting is an
important tool in recount and audits as
a way of verifying the machine count
tallying entire elections by hand would
cause chaos and make results less
accurate not more and sure enough early
voting in that county has been a
spectacular mess with the AP observing
two groups of five people spending about
three hours each counting just 50
ballots with mismatched tallies leading
to recounts and occasionally more
recounts and one volunteer lamenting I
can't believe it's taking two hours to
get through 25 ballots and yeah if only
there was a [ __ ] machine that could
help you guys with that
and and that is just one election denier
at a low level wreaking havoc we could
be in for a lot worse just look at
Arizona a state that Biden won by an
extremely narrow margin but thanks to
their then Governor doing one of the
most brutal call screenings of all time
things didn't go off the rails but he is
on his way out now and the Republican
nominee to replace him is running ads
like this hi Arizona I'm Kerry Lake the
Trump endorsed candidate for governor if
you're watching this ad right now it
means you're in the middle of watching a
fake news program you know how to know
it's fake because they won't even cover
the biggest story out there the rigged
election of 2020. okay except every bit
of that is wrong the election was not
rigged and the news did Cover both the
recounts and the lawsuits plus if you
just saw that ad for the first time on
this show you're clearly not watching it
on a fake news program you're watching
it because you left the TV on after the
White Lotus that is what is happening
right now
and that ad which includes footage from
2 000 mules by the way is actually tame
compared to some of the other things
that Lakers said because she's called
for the imprisonment of the current
Secretary of State and said that if she
didn't win her primary it'd be because
there's some cheating going on and then
after winning it insisted her supporters
had simply outvoted the fraud which is
basically if I lose it's rigged if I win
it's fine meaning that she's approaching
elections with the same objectivity and
Nuance of a five-year-old inventing a
game in real time the rules are simple
Whoever has the most tokens wins unless
you have the most tokens then it's who
can hold their breath the longest unless
you can then it's a jumping contest
but it gets worse for Arizona because
the Republican nominee for Secretary of
State there is Mark fincham who as you
can see wakes up every day to cosplay as
a cowboy accountant and he seems pretty
unlikely to willingly certify a
democratic win in his State given that
he said this would you ever accept that
a Democrat could win Arizona or or do
you just not think that's possible I
have a hard time believing that's
possible
Everywhere I Go
the vast majority of people
still show support for president Trump
but that might just be because you are
going to places
where there are supporters of Donald
Trump is there any chance a Democratic
candidate for president can win Arizona
in 2024.
a question with a frop or that he
apparently tells people no so often he
needed a special fun button for it
although between that he's talking Trump
doll and his novelty desk sign it's
slightly heartwarming to know the
dispenser's gifts in Arizona is staying
afloat thanks to the compulsive
purchases of one supremely weird
individual
but the thing is quiet up over there has
openly told supporters in a fundraising
email that if he had been in power in
2020 we would have won plain and simple
and in a debate he even brainstormed one
scenario of how that could have happened
knowing what we know today
there are certain counties that should
have been set aside as irredeemably
compromised Maricopa County was one of
them Yuma County was one of them we have
so many votes outside of the law
that it begs the question what do we do
with an election where we have votes
that are in the Stream
but should not be counted
if you can't find the individual who is
engaged in that behavior
perhaps that county has had a defective
election yeah he just laid his plan out
in front of everybody step one Identify
two large counties which if removed from
the count would hand the election to
Trump step two remove them from the
count
now is that a conspiracy to steal the
election well as we now know there are
no conspiracies but there are also no
coincidences in the famous words of one
Stephen Kevin Banner
and here is the thing any one of the
people that you've seen so far would be
bad in the wake of an election but in
combination things could get really
rough because there are protections
against one Rogue official refusing to
sign off on an election they could be
sued and if they refuse they could be
held in contempt of court but experts
warned that the ability of a governor or
Secretary of State to reject
certification are significantly enhanced
if others up and down the chain are of a
similar mind and to understand a
potential worst case scenario here let's
put some of the people that you've seen
tonight into a chain let's start with
partisan poll workers inspired by Steve
Bannon deciding that they've seen
something fishy and calling 9-1-1 they
then kick their claims up to a county
clerk like this guy who's maybe willing
to amplify a perception that's not a
reality that raises enough of a stink
that people at the County Board of
canvases or the State Board refuse to
sign off on the results and then the
Secretary of State takes their side
refusing to certify the results or even
arguing that the results from certain
counties are so flawed that the County's
election has failed and therefore cannot
be counted now in that scenario experts
say a Republican state legislature could
point to supposed irregularities in the
conduct of the election and choose their
own slate of electors to deliver a
different result and at this point the
law is a little fuzzy on what could
happen next because under the Electoral
count Act of 1887 if the state sends two
rival slates of electors and the house
and the Senate disagree on which one is
valid the one sent by the state's
Governor gets counted which could be
this person now they would undoubtedly
be lawsuits and maybe the Supreme Court
would step in but also you know seeing
as one of the justices has a wife who
was part of the last attempted coup
maybe not and I know this all sounds
dramatic and I do not want to be too
alarmist I don't mean to sound like
Chicken Little here I mean I don't mean
to look like him either but some things
are just out of our hands aren't they
because the odds of Curry Lake
unilaterally picking our next president
are thankfully slim but the odds of her
and others like her being able to create
a complete mess are significantly higher
because everything that we've talked
about tonight has the capacity to
overwhelm our system making it harder to
certify elections quickly leading to
confusion which sows doubt in the
process and in turn causes absolute
chaos which is very worrying given that
we've all seen what confused but
motivated people are capable of doing
when they think the process is broken
and we may not have to wait until 2024
to see that chaos unfold as the midterms
themselves are turning into a
[ __ ] Vigilantes are already
turning up as unofficial poll Watchers
at voting drop boxes meanwhile some very
prominent voices on the right have been
priming people to contest any result on
Tuesday that is not a republican win the
Democratic party has such contempt for
voters and for democracy itself and so
much confidence in its ownership of the
media end of big Tech that it no longer
has to try to win your votes they can
even run mentally defective candidates
who can barely speak and only expect
them to win but expect you to accept the
outcome no matter how transparently
absurd it is look I get that at this
point Tucker Carlson is basically Coco
melon for bigots but that is gross even
for him from calling a stroke victim
mentally defective to putting win in
heavy quotation marks and for the record
one of the big clues that these
conspiracy theories are [ __ ] is that
so many of them are predicated on the
belief that the Democratic party is well
organized who on Earth is stupid enough
to buy that [ __ ]
so so what can we do here well there are
some obvious steps that we should take
on the federal level we absolutely have
to fix the Electoral count act the law
whose vagueness allows for a lot of the
[ __ ] that I've just described both
the house and the Senate actually have
bills that have bipartisan support and
would among other things close the
failed election loophole that might
allow a partisan Governor or state
legislature to send whatever electors
they choose even Mitch McConnell has
supported the Senate version so it
actually might have a chance to pass
that is the one piece of good news in
this entire piece so I strongly suggest
that you savor it but but that is
clearly not enough long term we still
need comprehensive voting rights reform
which is something we need to prioritize
and fight for but the first step and I
know this is going to be infuriating to
here is for you to vote we've talked a
lot about how part of the reason that
Biden's Victory wasn't stolen from him
was thanks to the diligent work of a few
people in key positions but don't forget
that the first part of why that was
possible is that a lot of people [ __ ]
voted and I get how ludicrous it sounds
for someone to say fix these significant
roadblocks keeping your vote from
counting by voting I hear it I promise I
do particularly if you're a member of
one of the many communities like black
voters the disabled the formerly
incarcerated and low-income communities
who have long been sounding the alarm
about all of this [ __ ] and voting is not
going to be enough on its own at every
level of the process we need people to
show the same level of enthusiasm for
preserving our democracy that others are
demonstrating for dismantling it and I
am not saying it's going to be easy to
match the energy of people fueled by
[ __ ] documentaries flat out lies and
the occasional exploding trash can but
it is really important to try and to
that end we actually have a message that
we'd like you to hear hey Nick Offerman
here actor Arthur woodworker and a man
who can actually pull off a short sleeve
polo shirt without looking like my mommy
picked it out for me and this is a trash
can I've labeled it trash can because it
is a trash can I actually labeled it
twice so there won't be any Mix-Ups but
obviously that's unnecessary because
we're all adults who do know the
difference between a trash can and a
goddamn voting machine
far-right Republican extremists have
been running their dry mouths claiming
that any election in which they receive
less votes than the opposition must be
rigged well I've got some news for you
actual Patriots are sick and tired of
Shameless opportunistic charlatans who
invent dangerous conspiracies peddle
mendacious propaganda and worse
censor good good dogs
if you're afraid to show a dog's face by
God I'm not
good boy
you can't stop us from showing dogs just
like you can't stop us from voting we're
gonna do it not because it's fun because
it's not really fun but because it's the
right thing to do America
and guess what we're gonna look one [ __ ]
of a lot better than you while we do it
one shot no cuts
vote
and that's our show thanks for watching
see you next week